bonjour celle ci sera comment allez-vous
ça va bon vous venez sur ces votre
muguet dac
8h30 le premier client de la journée
arrive le muguet du 1er mai impossible
c'est la tradition quand même si je
n'entre pas du muguet tous les ans à ma
femme je vais me sentir
impossible également de ne pas profiter
de l'occasion pour isabelle bourgoin qui
n'a pas vu un client depuis un mois et
demi je pouvais pas rester sans rien
faire et un mes fournisseurs de la
région m'a contacté pour faire une
action pour vendre du muguet nantais
pour essayer de sauver d'aidé du moins
la production nantaise donc j'ai sauté
sur l'occasion
elle s'est organisée à communiquer par
afficher sur les réseaux sociaux est
reçue ainsi une centaine de commandes
toutes réservées et vendu sur des plages
horaires en d'agavé aujourd'hui pour que
les clients ne se croise pas la
fermeture de la boutique mi mars a été
un choc pour elle je suis revenu au
magasin le soir et puis je me suis dit
va falloir quand même que je réagisse se
bouge donc dans un premier temps j'ai
nettoyé ma boutique vie d'amy stocks
j'ai tout mis à l'extérieur tout ce qui
était plantes fleurs qui était
susceptible de l'intéresser les clients
j'ai tout mis devant ma vitrine avec une
pancarte servez-vous s'est offert plutôt
que de jeter je préférais données et
puis il ya eu aussi le sentiment
d'inutilité quand des clients appelés
pour un décès et qu'elle ne pouvait pas
honorer la commande et voilà les
deuxièmes depuis l'annnonce que sa
boutique pourra rouvrir après le 11 mai
elle dire vivre c'est pour elle et pour
tous les producteurs quelle fait
travailler un argument partagé
d'ailleurs par certains clients
on soutient isabelle et puis on soutient
producteurs nantais français qui c'est
le seul moment où il va vendre son
muguet donc oui je fais la collecte pour
mes collègues de travail je vais
travailler après si on en profite et je
suis à crasé avec le muguet d'isabelle
et du nantais produits cette expérience
a donné une idée à isabelle dès la
semaine prochaine
elle proposera des bouquets avec des
fleurs de saison des bouquets vendus là
encore sur commande et en livraison ou
sur le pas du magasin
merci beaucoup